[Música]
imaginas un país que regará las plantas
con agua salada un país que haya
conseguido transformar un árido y
estéril desierto en frondosos campos de
cultivo un país que situado en uno de
los lugares más áridos y secos de la
tierra haya sido capaz de hacerse con un
suministro casi ilimitado de agua pues
queridos amigos amigas No se trata de
ningún Espejismo ese lugar existe gran
parte de su territorio se asienta sobre
los desiertos de neguev y de judea y su
nombre es Israel hablamos del único país
de todo el planeta tierra que hoy tiene
menos superficie de desierto que hace 50
años por si fuera poco cada año el país
exporta más de 2.000 millones de dólares
en productos agrícolas sobre todo
productos frescos como frutas y
vegetales y esto es exactamente sobre lo
que os vamos a hablar en este vídeo
sobre cómo Israel ha sido capaz de
convertir al mismo desierto en todo un
Vergel sobre cómo este país ha superado
la escasez del agua por cierto apunte
Este vídeo lo hemos preparado gracias
nuestra comunidad de patreon Allí es
donde se escogió precisamente este tema
así que está especialmente dedicado a
todos los que nos apoyáis en patreon
arranquemos
[Música]
un informe confidencial del Consejo
Nacional de inteligencia de los Estados
Unidos publicado en 2012 y más tarde
desclasificado parcialmente apuntado a
una futura crisis cítrica una enorme
crisis del agua a nivel mundial según
este informe el consumo de agua se
situaría por encima de cualquier
parámetro sostenible cada vez somos más
y cada vez gastamos más agua consumimos
más carne tenemos más jardines más
piscinas y consumimos más energía
todo ello son cosas que podéis creerme
requieren de muchísima agua por ejemplo
producir un kilo tan solo un kilo de
carne consume 17 veces más agua que
producir un kilo de maíz de esta forma
el informe coincidía con otras
informaciones de expertos en que más del
20% de la población mundial más de 1.500
millones de personas sufrirán y mucho
con esta crisis hídrica Durante las
próximas décadas 1500 millones de
personas que tendrán serios pero que muy
serios problemas para acceder a un
suministro regular de agua hablamos
amigos de una crisis que pondrían
hackear todo el sistema alimentario
mundial y que no penséis ni por un
instante que se limitaría castigar a los
países más pobres por ejemplo el valle
de San Joaquín en California en el
centro el corazón de la agricultura de
calidad californiana podría desaparecer
al menos Tal y como y lo conocemos y eso
eso es lo que ha hecho que en este vídeo
nos hagamos una pregunta estamos a casos
condenados a no Tener suficiente agua
pues queridos amigos amigas creo que ha
llegado el momento de echar un vistazo a
uno de los lugares más áridos yernos de
todo el planeta
[Música]
Ni más ni menos que el 60% del
territorio israelí está cubierto por el
desierto lo que explica que la relación
de este pueblo con el agua sea tan
estrecha que está presente
constantemente ya sea en la cultura la
política o incluso En la religión de
hecho una de las oraciones judías más
conocidas el sema advierte que el
castigo por no cumplir los mandamientos
de Dios será precisamente que la lluvia
dejará de caer
a pesar de ello tal y como seguramente
todo sepáis Israel es un país próspero
un importante exportador agroalimentario
y tiene un suministro abundante y
garantizado de agua de hecho Incluso le
suministra agua a sus vecinos Así que la
pregunta la gran pregunta que podemos
hacernos es como demonios han logrado
superar las casas del agua que podemos
aprender de ellos nos enfrentamos a un
futuro con agua o con sed en este vídeo
os vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes antes tenemos que
empezar por el principio tenemos que ver
un poquito de historia
[Música]
las arterias de Israel
a finales de los años 20 los economistas
que asesoraban al gobierno británico que
en aquel momento era quien controlaba
este territorio afirmaron que la
inmigración de más judíos a Palestina no
era sostenible y no lo era porque según
sus cálculos los recursos hídricos eran
tan limitados que era imposible que
pudieran vivir más de 2 millones de
personas tirando por lo alto Sí lo sé
hoy viven más de 12 millones ya sabéis
las previsiones El caso es que desde ese
preciso momento las organizaciones
judías de la zona entendieron Pues que
Su futuro pasaba por incrementar los
recursos hídricos tenían que encontrar
agua a toda Costa para los campos de
cultivo para los nuevos colonos que
pudieran llegar y para poder construir
un nuevo Israel
Pero había un problema la mayor parte
del país era desértico árido y seco los
recursos hídricos disponibles se
concentraban en el norte pero los judíos
estaban Estableciendo mayoritariamente
en torno a la nueva gran urbe de la
región de la vip situada en el centro
del país Así que para resolver este
embrollo tras la publicación del informe
británico en 1939 le encargaron uno de
los ingenieros hidráulicos más reputados
del país sin hablas un inmigrante polaco
que diseñará un plan hídrico Ni más ni
menos que el plan que tenía que
garantizar el futuro de Israel
[Música]
y sabéis que dicho y hecho eso fue
exactamente lo que hizo haciendo gala de
todo su Ingenio y atrevimiento el señor
Blas diseñó un plan de tres fases
prácticamente el plan que se ejecutó
durante décadas y que hizo posible El
despegue demográfico y económico de
Israel veréis la primera fase que
consistía en la extracción de agua
mediante perforaciones profundas el
señor Blas estaba convencido de que bajo
el subsuelo de Israel Incluso en zonas
tan áridas como el desierto del neguev
había agua Así que se propuso
encontrarla para abastecer nuevos
establecimientos agrícolas Claro que
incluso de tener éxito esa operación no
sería suficiente el país tenía que
aprovechar hasta la última gota que
hubiera disponible es decir tenían que
conseguir trasladar el agua desde donde
era relativamente abundante hasta donde
hacía falta exactamente por eso las dos
siguientes fases respondieron
precisamente a esta idea
la segunda fase tenía como objetivo
bombear agua desde el río Jordán el río
más importante de la región hasta el
sureste llegando incluso hasta el
mismísimo desierto del negué una zona
inhabitada el cual los nuevos colonos
podrían instalarse y hacer crecer sus
campos de cultivo
pero con mucha muchísima diferencia la
parte más importante del plan fue la
tercera fase la construcción de la
acueducto nacional hablamos de un enorme
trasvase de más de 100 kilómetros que
tenía que trasladar agua desde el norte
del país especialmente desde el mar de
Galilea el lago de Agua Dulce más grande
del país hasta donde hiciera falta
conectando además los recursos
desarrollados en las fachas anteriores
En otras palabras lo que el señor Blas
propuso fue un enorme plan de inversión
para construir las arterias de Israel
esto es un enorme sistema hídrico que
lograra garantizar el acceso al agua
dulce a lo largo y ancho de todo el país
y ojo porque si algo estaba claro es que
poner en marcha este plan era algo muy
pero que muy urgente fijaos
[Música]
el día de la declaración de
independencia del Estado hebreo el 14 de
mayo de 1948 Israel tenía 806.000
habitantes prácticamente en los
siguientes tres años llegaron al país
700.000 personas más evidentemente la
mayor parte de ellas procedentes del
viejo continente para atender de a
tantas personas alimentarlas y lograr
que encontrasen un trabajo para
subsistir hacía falta mucha muchísima
agua de esta forma la restricciones de
agua Se volvieron cada vez más exigentes
y poner en marcha el plan de sin jaulas
era algo de máxima urgencia
El problema es que hacía falta mucho
dinero y no estamos hablando de un país
precisamente rico por aquel entonces por
no hablar de que los pocos recursos de
los que disponía el nuevo gobierno
israelí Pues iban a parar en gran medida
a la seguridad y la defensa entonces La
pregunta es cómo hacerlo Pues fue justo
aquí cuando el por aquel entonces Primer
Ministro de Israel bengurión tomó una de
las decisiones más polémicas de toda la
historia de Israel una decisión que pudo
incluso terminar desembocando en todo un
conflicto civil
[Música]
a comienzos de la década de los 50
bengurión aceptó firmar un acuerdo de
reparación con la República Federal
alemana de conratas de nauer un acuerdo
por el que el estado de Israel recibió
una indemnización de 3000 millones de
Marcos Como compensación por los
crímenes nazis y el robo y la
destrucción de propiedades judías
Durante los tiempos del Tercer Reich
fue algo tremendamente impopular a
aceptar una compensación por tantísimo
dolor muchos israelíes sintieron que se
Estaba comprando su dolor que se estaba
mercantilizando con uno de los sucesos
más trágicos de la historia de la
humanidad hubo protestas manifestaciones
enfrentamientos violentos con las
fuerzas de seguridad y al final el
parlamento israelí aprobó el acuerdo por
tan solo dos votos de diferencias
a pesar de todo ya había dinero el
trasvase del río Jordán se completó en
1955 y Durante los siguientes años el
país se puso literalmente patas arriba y
el acueducto nacional supuso construir
tuberías canales y pequeños embalses por
toda la geografía nacional la propia red
principal tenía que ser básicamente
subterránea Y ser capaz de soportar
cualquier ataque que se pudiera producir
trabajaron miles y miles de personas en
este inmensa obra y el gasto per cápita
fue mayor que el del mismísimo canal de
Panamá pero finalmente en 1964 el
acueducto nacional fue una realidad el
suministro de agua estaba por fin
garantizado en todo el país amigos sin
ahora podemos decir que el enorme
crecimiento económico y demográfico que
Israel ha experimentado simple y
llanamente no hubiera sido posible ahora
bien hoy Israel tiene más de 9 millones
de habitantes y una economía moderna Así
que hacía falta hacer más mucho más
[Música]
Israel necesita más agua
con el comienzo del siglo XXI los
problemas con el suministro de agua
volvieron a estar una vez más sobre la
mesa y fue aquí cuando se puso en marcha
toda una nueva Revolución y es que
veréis en 2006 se tomó la decisión de
transferir la gestión del sistema de
agua desde el nivel político al nivel
tecnocrático esto es los políticos
dejaron de estar al frente y se creó la
autoridad del agua de Israel una agencia
cuya misión pues es gestionar el sistema
de forma profesional y vaya si lo
hicieron en 2008 esta autoridad del agua
tomó una decisión muy pero que muy
controvertida todo el mundo tendría que
pagar el precio real que costaba
suministrar el agua hasta ese momento
tal y como ocurre en la mayor parte de
países del Mundo Pues el precio del agua
estaba subvencionado por el gobierno la
gente entiende que el agua es un tesoro
pero no comprende por tiene que pagarla
ven la lluvia y creen que el agua es
gratis Y tienen razón ese agua es gratis
pero el agua asegura confiable y siempre
disponible no es gratis y no puede serlo
la construcción de infraestructuras no
es gratis miembro de alto rango de la
autoridad del agua de Israel la medida
tenía dos objetivos muy claros por un
lado impulsar el ahorro de agua ya sabes
si tienes que pagar más pues gastas
menos y por otro incrementar los
ingresos del sistema para poder así
construir más infraestructuras y mejorar
su mantenimiento Pero eso eso no fue
todo
[Música]
esta agencia también le retiró a los
ayuntamientos el control de la
distribución del agua y la gestión de
las aguas residuales a cambio que un
sistema de 55 empresas municipales que
tenían que funcionar con criterios de
mercado para gestionar toda la red el
dinero recaudado ya no iría a Los
presupuestos municipales sino a mejorar
el sistema Por ejemplo a evitar las
fugas de agua de las tuberías que muchas
ciudades supone perder más del 30% de
todo el agua el que en Israel está muy
por debajo del 10%
además de esta forma si un alcalde pues
quiere regar los parques municipales ya
no tiene agua gratis para hacerlo tiene
que pagar el precio real la medida
amigos fue un completo y rotundo éxito
sin tener que limitar el suministro el
consumo de aguas Residencial pública y
Privada cayó casi un 20% en todo el país
por ejemplo en los parques y jardines
pues se sustituyeron muchas plantas por
otras mejor adaptadas a la zona que
consumían menos agua y luego en la
agricultura pues pasó tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo
y eso no es todo para impulsar la
innovación en materia del agua el
gobierno estableció planes de apoyo a la
inversión en Innovación de estas nuevas
empresas lidera Convertir las ciudades
israelíes en Auténticos laboratorios del
agua las empresas compiten por los
fondos al tiempo que las innovaciones
les permiten mejorar su hoja de
resultados
[Música]
y así así es exactamente cómo se venció
de nuevo a la sequía Durante los
primeros años de este siglo XXI pero
sabéis que aún no hemos terminado porque
una cosa es evitar la sequía y otra muy
distinta tener todo el agua que quieras
y además convertirlo en un gran negocio
y eso eso es exactamente lo que Israel
ha conseguido atento
en el Ingenio está la clave
amigos Israel es un país conocido por
tres cosas el mosad la eficacia de sus
fuerzas armadas y también la innovación
de hecho es conocido como la startup
nation y en el caso de la gestión del
agua que es todo una prioridad nacional
pues no iba a ser diferente
especialmente en el campo de la
agricultura que al fin y al cabo supone
el 55% de todo el consumo de agua de
Israel y sí fue precisamente en este
país donde se produjo una de las grandes
revoluciones agrícolas de las últimas
décadas el riego por goteo una técnica
que permite ahorrar hasta el 60% del
agua al tiempo que mejora el rendimiento
de los cultivos Hablamos de una técnica
que consiste en regar una planta gota
gota directamente a la raíz y que los
últimos años ha sido mejorada con el
conocido como fertiriego esto es un
riego por goteo en el que se incluye
también Gota a gota los fertilizantes e
incluso con el nutririego el no va más
de la tecnología agrícola en este caso
por ejemplo mediante el riego por goteo
se suministra todo lo que las plantas
necesitan para crecer de tal forma que
incluso se pueden desarrollar en unas
plantaciones sobre la mismísima arena
del desierto con el nutririego los
crecen en cualquier lado la arena del
desierto se puede utilizar para mantener
la planta en su lugar y el agua con
nutrientes es administrada por el riego
por goteo que se encarga del resto
Racing e incluso ahora están
introduciendo diminutos dispositivos que
se colocan en las raíces y detectan
cuando hay que regar exactamente las
plantas Pues bien El caso es que todas
estas tecnologías han sido desarrolladas
sobre todo por empresas israelíes pero
ahí hay tampoco queda todo Otro campo en
el que los israelíes son especialmente
buenos es en el de las semillas tanto de
las semillas tradicionales como de las
modificadas genéticamente algo que les
ha permitido por ejemplo reducir el
consumo de agua de cada planta e incluso
atentos han desarrollado semillas que se
pueden regar con agua ligeramente salada
como es el agua salobre que es un tipo
de agua de la que hay una enorme
cantidad en el subsuelo de todo Oriente
medio pero que siempre se pensó pues que
no valía para nada sí sí tal cual como
lo escucháis en Israel podéis
encontrarlos con melones tomates
pimientos o yo que sé berenjenas entre
otras muchas clases de frutas y verduras
que son regadas con una mezcla de agua
dulce y agua salada y aún aún hay más
junto a la infraestructura ligada al
acueducto nacional Durante los últimos
años este país ha desarrollado una
segunda infraestructura Para repartir
las aguas residuales depuradas por todo
el país de tal forma que Ni más ni menos
que el 85% de todas ellas se reutilizan
para qué Pues básicamente para la
agricultura y también para regar por
ejemplo parques o campos de golf
no hay nada parecido en el resto del
mundo y para colmo Israel también se ha
convertido en uno de los líderes
mundiales en la tecnología de la
desalinización de hecho una de las
mayores plantas por volumen y eficacia
de todo el planeta se encuentra
Precisamente en el entorno de tel aviv
la planta sorek que es capaz de procesar
más de 600 millones de litros de agua al
día y así de esta forma es como Israel
ha vencido a las sequías que llevaban
azotando esta región del mundo desde
hace milenios Israel un país enclavado
en un terreno seco y árido hoy tiene
todo el suministro de agua que pueda
necesitar e incluso le suministra agua
Palestina y también a Jordania todo lo
ha conseguido mediante la ingeniería a
la innovación y también el sistema de
precios pero llegados hasta aquí turno
para ti qué te parece la puesta de
Israel por el agua crees que es el
camino a seguir para evitar una crisis
hídrica déjanos por aquí abajo tu
respuesta en los comentarios y ya sabéis
si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante No olvides darle al botón de
like y antes de terminar Muchas gracias
a todos los que nos apoyáis en patreon
Espero que este vídeo que vosotros
mismos habéis escogido os haya gustado
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]